hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
mir wurde sehr häufig in die kommentare
geschrieben dass ich doch mal wieder
murphy bot spielen soll deswegen sehen
wir hier schon den chat verlauf
eingeblendet aus den letzten videos sei
murphy bord geht es nämlich darum dass
wir ich glaube kennt ihn murphy bord
mittlerweile schon oder hast du noch mal
alle dienen vielleicht nicht kennen uns
war es dass ein skype bot den man sowas
schreiben kann wie what if konkreter was
angela merkel oder sagt er wie ich als
angela merkel aussehen würde und
schickte davon bild das ist quasi alles
da bin ich wieder die kommentare unserem
letzten video hergegangen und habe mir
ein paar sachen rausgesucht die ich
jetzt einfach mal testen werde das erste
was man eben ist what if kong crafter
boss john cena das wort mit am meisten
gewünscht von allen usern irgendwie will
jeder sehen wie ich als schon ziele
aussehe deswegen schauen oder was der
mutter zu bestellen ist übrigens ein
bisschen havarie war gestern feiern
okay okay also es ist es ist wirklich
sehr schön geworden dieses bild das das
bin ich als john cena ski-nation john
cena also ich bin echt begeistert meine
augen sind sogar so grün wie der grüne
dings hier von john cena wenn man
eingeht what if kontrakte was john cena
kommt ein teil von dem video von den das
ist wieso wenn man frau kraft wieder
kommt ein video von oder allerdings vom
diener
was soll das motherboard auch sehr oft
kommentiert wurde wortes angela merkel
was katja krasa wie jetzt waren wir ganz
kurz ab was der profi bot da raus und da
bin ich jetzt echt mega gespannt freunde
ein paar sekunden später oh mein gott
alter was zum was ist das als er das ist
was das ist doch das ekel mich was
tatsächlich auch kommentiert wurde war
roger kong crafter strain das bin ich
als zug- und ich finde so schlecht sich
ein okay ich doch es sieht schon sehr
verstörend aus tatsächlich what if
kontrakt aber aus mister bean bin ich
jetzt selber relativ gespannt wie das
ganze aussehen wir alles klar murphy bot
dass das ist super schön geworden dieses
bild das ist sogar das erste mal das ist
irgendwie so aussieht wie ich als fusion
mit
mid mid mid es ist tatsächlich sehr gut
geworden ist muss ich sagen waters
kontrast harry potter wurde tatsächlich
auch die kommentare geschrieben deswegen
schauen wir mal was ja irgendwie
kommentiert das video die ganze zeit
gleich sowie das wurde in die kommentare
geschrieben deswegen schauen wir mal was
dabei okay sehr schön meine schnauze in
harry potter zusammen mit hermann i
wundervoll wirklich wundervoll ich weiß
nicht wie man noch was kommt arbeitet
dieter bohlen du hast kim kardashian
wurde auch in die kommentare geschrieben
der murphy bord überlegt und sagt uns
dass das bild tatsächlich so aussieht
ich glaube wir haben die verstört skala
gerade total durchbrochen oben weil das
ist echt verstörend hier bin ich
eigentlich der einzige der kim
kardashian nicht geil findet also sehr
viele feiern die ja und ihren style aber
ich finde dass ist das nicht schön ist
also ich weiss nicht ewig so unnatürlich
auf mich also ich keine ahnung das
wollte ich nur mal kurz sagen also
vielleicht in der kim kardashian
supporter gar nichts gegen euch oder so
möchte ich halt immer mit wie alle sagen
wo audi so toll der von tollen star
david beckham ist nicht schön
es wurde auch in die kommentare
geschrieben worte von craft aber steve
also was wir werden also dieses tief von
minecraft denke ich jetzt mal und wenn
man das eigene dann bin ich tatsächlich
nicht jetzt die von minecraft wars die
von minecraft vielleicht also wenn ich
dem weg über direct sage das weil er
suche jetzt quasi einerseits von kraft
an einerseits dass hinter dem haus also
steve von minecraft das heißt ich sehe
das bin ich als minecraft figur ist ist
tatsächlich sehr komisch ich weiß nicht
was ich dazu sagen soll was ich wirklich
auch den kommentaren gelesen habe ist
what if kong crafter bosse polster
deswegen mal ganz kurz an dieser stelle
wenn ihr unter 18 seid klickt das video
jetzt weg okay ich weiß nicht was da
jetzt kommt der map-report überlegt
gerade noch jetzt schickt er mir
wahrscheinlich wieder jeden moment die
smileys jetzt kommt tatsächlich
es ist es ist hier es kommt es kommt
dass es nicht auf konkrete was uns da
wenn ich das eingebe kommt der will
nicht dass sie waren ganz sachen die ich
mir jetzt vom video aufgeschrieben habe
und das habe ich jetzt alles
nachgeschaut bei murphy bot das meist
dadurch gefunden polster hat er
irgendwie will er mir wahrscheinlich
nicht anzeigen der film von dieter
bohlen und kim kardashian muss ich
wirklich sagen ist so das verstörendste
bild was ich bisher je gesehen habe das
ist dass sie echt creepy aus dieser
person an dieser stelle würde ich dann
allerdings auch dass auch mein gott das
war gerade total unscharf alles wieder
negativ schmidt face kampflos halten
schnauzte du scheiß ding an dieser
stelle werde ich das video bei der damen
und herren ich hoffe euch hat es
gefallen wenn das getan hat dann freue
ich mich über eine bewertung von euch
und schreibt mir bitte wirklich jetzt
wieder in die kommentare
vorschläge die ich das nächste mal dem
keyboard fragen soll also beispielsweise
so was wie what if kongress angela
merkel oder sonst das war s dann jetzt
auch von mir